i only had a heart
well would you take a pig heart
this man did
57 year old david bennett received a
heart transplant this week from a
genetically modified pig
so this raises three questions why
how and what now
so why well he needed a heart
there is currently a huge shortage for
organs 17 people in the us die every day
waiting for a transplant and there are
more than a hundred thousand apparently
waiting
and this number is only expected to grow
as the population increases and gets
older
but i think you're more wondering why a
pig
well anatomically speaking pigs are
quite similar to us humans
their hearts are a similar size to our
own
and the fancy term for having an organ
from a different species in this case a
pig is cno transplantation
the sort of just one major thing that
hinders this process
well it's from a pig
and similarly to how our bodies mount an
immune response to pathogens when we get
sick
pigs have molecular differences which
make them incompatible to humans
effectively
our body would recognize the pig heart
as foreign and try to get rid of it
and this is also a problem with human
organ transplants as we're all
genetically different
unless you have an identical twin of
course and so many patients who've had
organ transplants take
immunosuppressants for the remainder of
their life
this can have side effects such as
reducing their general immune response
which may make them vulnerable to other
infections as well as the trouble of
remembering to take them daily
but there are far more differences
between pigs and humans than between
humans so how is this pig heart
transplant possible
well the pig from which the heart came
from was genetically modified
and this technology was developed by the
company revival
although they're not actually the only
company attempting to do similar changes
with pig organs to make them human
compatible
but their approach involved making 10
genetic changes
so what were they
well firstly what they needed to do was
to remove any molecular
incompatibilities on the pig cells and
to do that they had to silence three
different genes that encode enzymes that
can add these different sugars to the
surface of pixels that are recognized by
the human immune response
but besides silencing these genes they
also added human genes to the pigs
two anti-inflammatory genes
two genes that promote normal blood
coagulation and prevent blood vessel
damage
and two other regulatory proteins that
help dampen down antibody response
and a final modification remove the gene
for a growth hormone receptor to reduce
the chance that a pig organ will outgrow
once it's implanted
and this builds upon a paper that came
out last year where they showed that
this modification reduced the growth of
pig hearts transplanted into baboons
and so hopefully this will also
translate in the case with david
and so once they've made these genetic
changes to pig cells
using gene editing they can then use a
process known as nuclear transfer to
eventually generate genetically
engineered pigs
and if that wasn't enough david's also
been given an experimental drug kpl 4a4
that is an antibody drug that reduces
the activity of some of his immune cells
so an antibody immunosuppressant
so what now
well now i feel like we need to address
the elephant in the room well in this
case pig the ethical issues
for david this approach was a last hope
of saving his life
it was either die or do this transplant
however some of the ethical issues that
have arisen include patient safety
animal rights and religious concerns
regarding patient safety
david knew the risks and as i quoted
earlier he had no other option
the fda made a special exception to
allow this procedure for him though if
there is another patient in a similar
situation the team may apply for another
fda approval for a human clinical trial
will only come pending promising data
from the use of pig hearts and baboons
which brings me on to the next concern
animal rights
one organization
people for the ethical treatment of
animals has condemned mr bennett's
picard transplant as unethical dangerous
and a tremendous waste of resources
animals aren't tool sheds to be raided
but complex intelligent beings
now it's me so i didn't want to end the
story there
what alternative future strategies could
we see employed to overcome some of
these ethical considerations
well an obvious one to improve safety
would be to have organs from our own
bodies as this would prevent rejection
it would use a combination of cellular
reprogramming and stem cells
we looked last year at some mouse work
showing in five reprogramming to improve
heart health and mice
and so human application will surely at
some point be developed
and alternatively to that
some companies are developing mechanical
organs
so a mechanical heart though this may
raise more ethical considerations if it
turns out mechanical organs enhance
performance over organs we currently
have
so we can't ignore the ethical issues
but that doesn't mean that this advance
isn't exciting and as the ceo of refiver
course says this is not a one-off we're
going to take this all the way through
to human clinical trials and hopefully
have an unlimited supply of donor organs
and as i mentioned earlier five o'clock
not the only company doing this
e-genesis is also investigating cna
transplantation
but until they release further
information i can't comment on how it
differs to refiver core but ultimately
the ethical concerns are going to remain
the same
so anyway i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening